Kelly Joe starts off this hour and
Dayton Ohio
hi Kelly Joe how are you I want are you
better than I deserve what's up okay so
I've got a question my husband and I we
live in a home he purchased about seven
years ago with his ex-wife we have five
children for his and one of ours and we
currently know about 125 on this home
the equity that we have in it's about
sixty thousand and if we were to sell it
now we'd walk away between lips between
seventy and eighty thousand dollars
our current mortgage payment is thirteen
hundred a month and we have about forty
thousand dollars in debt between my
cards some student loan payments and
about three thousand dollars on the
credit cards so my question is he and I
are very much money to sell our home and
move but we are not in a position to buy
a home
he had a bankruptcy that was discharged
in 2014 so we have a couple more years
before he's actually able to be on a
mortgage and so we are looking at
possibly renting a home in our position
and briefly want to move it's because we
have a interested situation where his
ex-wife is actually our next-door
neighbor that is the reason to why we
really want to make me want to move
that's weird
how did that happen he already owned the
house when they got divorced so she goes
and buys the house next door and
actually she moved in with a neighbor
she was she was playing a little bit on
the side and ended up moving in with my
husband's best friend at the time who is
our neighbor so now we're all neighbors
I can't breathe your husband is probably
a saint because I would have had all not
shooting through the walls of that house
okay watch yes I've got to move I can't
stand it just I mean the money's a side
issue but Wow oh my gosh so he had a
bankruptcy win it was discharged in 2014
and he is the primary breadwinner so
with my income I can't be on
I can't get a mortgage sizable enough to
what we would need to house five
children and ourselves so we are pretty
much to wait two years away okay so
let's let me walk this through make sure
I've got this straight okay if you sell
your home your debt free and you have an
emergency fund and it is going to take
you four years from the time he got
discharged before you're going to be
bankable for a traditional mortgage
truck so you are going to be renting for
three two or three years but you'll be
debt-free you won't live next door to
his adulterous former ex oh my god
and and oh Lord
and uh and your debt free but you're not
a homeowner for three years well but you
got some reasonable boundaries in your
life and you are also debt free now the
trick here is this to make sure that the
emotions of this which are all very
reasonable everyone listening is going
oh my gosh
right can't believe you stayed there ten
minutes and you know that's we don't
want that to be the only don't don't let
those override wisdom so here's what has
to happen you guys have to be on a
written budget you have to pay your
landlord earlier on time you have to
raise your right hand and promise to
each other swear never to borrow money
again ever
yeah for anything ever ever
and if you can't do that then you know
this is not going to work out well for
you all right cuz you're gonna be back
in debt you're gonna be a renter you're
gonna be stuck you're gonna get behind
again cuz he's been behind before that's
how how long have y'all been married
just a year okay okay
so you know he doesn't have a good track
record with money agreed now agreed okay
and uh basically the two of you together
don't because you've run up $40,000
worth of debt some
they're between the two of you correct
so you got to make sure that that cycle
is broken with this process which then
allows you to be ready to really put
down a huge substantial wonderful
downpayment by the time his credit is
cleansed just with time well does that
make sense
welcome if you can promise no more debt
we're going to get control we're going
to save money we're going to be on a
written budget for the rest of our lives
we're never going back here again so
that we can prosper but also so we can
buy a home when we're ready three years
from now yeah I'd sell this house right
now and I'd be debt-free and I'd get on
a written budget I'd pile up cash
because all this money is calling out
the payments won't be going out anymore
well now have you guys read the book
have you read the book the Total Money
Makeover I let them all you haven't yet
but I happen ah see that's scary he is
on board with it you're totally on board
shorter lutely now sorta not on board is
not on board up brick she's listening
right now not on board enough to read a
book yeah okay all right so this is this
is the danger of this advice is if you
guys don't use while you're moving and
dude I'd move I'm out of there okay but
but uh while you're moving you need to
go ahead and change your life right
permanently so I want you to have you
been through Financial Peace University
never will he go if I give it to you
absolutely all right if you if I give it
to you you both have to attend class and
that will help us solidify this promise
that you're making to yourself it's not
going to affect my life by the way I'm
going to give you Financial Peace
University it's my gift to you too so
you can get out of weird land there and
get you to like get your life back
oh my gosh oh man I can't tell you how
fast I sold that house whooping caught
so fast oh man you guys would be so rich
so fast and be able to do so much not
only for yourselves and for your family
but for others
Oh